Candid Truth.
>> What is up everybody? Thank you for
joining us at Candid Truth. We're going
to talk about what we're up to and uh we
just wanted to say hi to you guys and
see you guys in the chat. Thank you guys
for being in here. If you've been
blessed by this ministry, give it a
simple and free thumbs up. It's a It's a
simple way to support this ministry, to
get our videos out there, to break the
algorithm because I believe that we're
being shadowbanned just to kind of fill
you guys in. Um, God put on our heart a
year and a half ago roughly to start
this ministry. We stepped away from a
full-time salary job with Little Light
Studios. We used to work with them and
stepped out in faith. Um, we get
questions all the time. Why did you guys
leave Little Light Studios? Did you get
fired? Was there any bad terms or
anything like that?
There was uh mainly I would say my mom
had a stroke four years ago. I'm an only
child. My dad was taking care of her by
herself. Thank God there's a a wonderful
friend out there named Judy Hunt. Thank
you so much for taking care of my mom.
My mom actually passed away in March.
But um when we started this ministry, it
was because I felt a great need to be
more available to help my dad with my
mom because there was a lot of times she
she went when she had the stroke, it um
it really did a toll on her where she
was almost like an infant. like her mind
was just not there anymore and she
>> physically could get up and walk out the
door or try to pick up a cleaning
product and try to drink it or
something. So, it was like a really
stressful time on my dad to um he still
had to work and all that stuff. And and
hey, I see Carol with a K. What's up? We
love you. And uh so we're going to get
into some of the things that we've been
doing. But
>> I, you know, I felt the need the last
year that I was with Little Life
Studios. I'm doing what I love doing.
I'm creating the video, getting the
truth out there. And then it would hit
me, man, my mom's going through this. My
dad's having to take care of all by
myself. And then I'd get a call, you
know, sometimes from my dad being like,
man, I hate to disturb you. Is there any
way you could come help me? Like she
won't get out of the car. And it was
just
>> it was a living nightmare. And um I I
was just plagued with this thought like
how in how can I be more available. I
where I worked was like an hour from
their house and I'd have to ask
permission to leave and all that kind of
stuff. So, um, when me and Aubrey got
married, she had the same idea that she
felt the call to ministry. And I was
like, well,
>> well, I can add to that real quick.
Okay. And why here's a good example
because it was public. If you at all do
know about Little Light Studios and how
I was doing the holiday series with
them,
>> they promoted quite a few series coming
out. There's supposed to be three for
each quarter of the year to cover all of
the holidays in the year. And they only
did, I believe,
>> none.
>> None. We we did film the first one,
right?
>> And we did the intro to it, but that was
it.
>> And so that kind of made me feel like,
okay, there's something
>> uh kind of wrong here.
>> I'll just be very blunt because we need
to be talking about the holidays.
>> The holidays are not something we should
be keeping. And um they they nixed it.
They were like, "No, I don't think so.
We're not going to." Not that they kind
of I'm not sure where they stood
necessarily, but I think what their
comments were about directly was that
they didn't want to step on toes.
>> Yeah. It was a little too touchy, I
think.
>> And so, I just decided, you know what?
I have to stand up for truth and we need
to have our own channel
>> and we have to talk about what is true
no matter what, even if it does step on
toes.
>> And so, yeah. So for me, I was like,
well, that sounds like the answer
because I
there wasn't an opportunity to work from
home at Little Light or anything. And so
I'm like I don't know what to do. I was
in a situation I was like completely
stuck because I'm like I could quit my
job, but then I lose everything, you
know? I don't
>> I I I can't just walk away from my job
to help my parents and not have anything
as a backup. Mhm.
>> And um thankfully Aubrey had some
savings and we thought, you know, if
this is really God, we'll step out in
faith, try to make some videos.
If we don't get support right away,
we'll use this little bit of savings and
worst case scenario, if it just does it
flops, I'll just go back to work
somewhere, you know, get a 9 to5. So
there was a little bit of a cushion. And
after the first month,
uh we had enough to make our mortgage.
And when I say that, I don't mean the
house paid off. I mean the month uh that
that first month of uh our mortgage, but
then it was like, well, we still got
other bills. We got groceries and gas
and
uh electric, well, everything, you know,
all the bills.
>> Next month, we had enough to make the
mortgage and the bills. The next month,
the mortgage, the bills, and the
groceries the next month. And we started
praying, God, if this is really your
will for us, um we want to see it. We
want to see our pay get matched what we
had and it doesn't happen monthtomonth
because all of our finance all of our
finances come from donors like you
>> and we thank you so much for that. We
can't we literally can't do this without
you
>> and some months we get barely enough for
like our bills.
>> But then the next month somebody will
generously give a lot and we're like
wow. And when we look at the finances
every six months, because we've only
been doing this a year and a half, we've
looked at the finances for the the first
six months and the second six months,
and it was exactly what we used to make.
And so, we're like, "This is amazing."
We don't see it monthto month, but we
have faith. We keep going, and at the
end of the half of a year, we look and
we praise God that he is providing. And
so we're reaching the end of the year
again. Uh December, this is when people
or yeah, December is next month. We're
reaching the end of the year and this is
where people are looking for places to
give. And the Bible says you have not
because you ask not.
>> I hate asking. I never like asking, but
I've talked to people who say
>> they don't have a ministry. They're
like, "My ministry is I'm wealthy and I
want to give it to places, but I don't
know who needs it if nobody speaks up."
>> Right?
>> And so, this is our opportunity to just
say it's the end of the year. We are a
donationbased ministry. We give away
free books. We go anywhere. Somebody
will invite us. Even if we're not paid,
sometimes we do get paid. Sometimes just
our travels paid. We will go. We want
the truth out there and we're gonna show
you some of the places that we've been.
Um, I'll put it on here. If you see any
good comments, pull them up.
>> That one actually, we should probably
just tackle that. Someone asked, "Oh,
AD, you guys don't talk to Little Light
Studios anymore."
>> Yeah, we uh
>> we do.
>> I actually hung out with them two weeks
ago and I've been on two shows since we
parted ways. We see them at uh
conferences and stuff. It has nothing to
do with uh personal anything.
>> Yeah. It's just like in a congregation
there's people who
might have little tiny differences and
beliefs a little bit, but we it was
things we wanted to talk about that we
felt strongly about like the holidays or
kind of for me the holidays and some of
the pagan things that I wanted to expose
and they weren't exactly keen on that.
Like I said, they didn't want to step on
toes. And then for Mikey, there were
some other topics as well that he wanted
to talk about that were kind of um being
um muzzled, I think, as well. So, it's
okay. Like, they have they've got to do
what they got to do and they're going to
stand for what they believe in and you
can't change that. You still just have
to be brothers and sisters walking
together. So, that's what we do. We're
still friends.
>> Yep. And you know what? I didn't kind of
expect or think about really is like
there is a certain freedom in having
your own ministry. I mean if I get
invited to go speak somewhere
uh I'm going to go no matter what kind
of conference it is or you know this is
this is what kind of people would ask
they'll be like how come you associate
with those types of people and the the
accusation is like those people are
either you know they're not the same
they don't have the same belief system
or maybe they're a shill you know
they're actually you know what I will
speak truth anywhere the doors are
I'll go to Disney World and speak truth.
I'll go to the Mormon temple. I'll go to
the Satanic Temple. I will go anywhere
the doors are open
>> and stand in that stage and share the
truth.
>> Because what did Jesus say?
>> The doctor is for the sick, not the
well.
>> The the truth is for the lost, not the
righteous. Right?
>> And this is this is what it's all about.
Being a light shining in darkness. We
already have, you know, and this is what
I was praying this year. About the
middle of this year, I started fervently
praying, God, open up the doors for me
to speak outside the church walls. I'm
sick of preaching to the choir. I know
there's people in our churches that
still don't know the truths that we
share, and I I still love going to
churches, but I want to get outside the
church walls. And God opened up the
doors for three events
right after that. We went to Well, we
can talk about that. Um, I'll show you
where we went.
>> So, well, this wasn't this was not a
church either. This is actually a
college
>> full screen,
>> huh? It can't go full screen.
>> Oh, okay.
>> But it's it's on there. Um, so a college
campus called Southern Adventist
University in Chattanooga. And this was
actually like my third or fourth time
getting to go there and sharing my
testimony with the students there. And
this time was such a blessing. I'm
telling you, every time we get to go
over me,
>> God,
>> which has never happened before
>> and because they knew we have a new
ministry and all that,
>> you have brought him here
>> and just praying protection over me as I
go places. I share my testimony, you
know.
>> Yeah. I didn't know the the person
that's praying. I know her.
>> No way.
>> Wow. Okay. Well, you just saw that live.
>> Wow. I wasn't there for that day, so
Yep.
>> This is incredible.
>> Um,
>> that's amazing.
>> I got to I wish we were both in the
screen here. Okay.
>> Um,
>> a little more for you.
>> Thank you, Linda. God has blessed me
with an amazing testimony. He's pulled
me out of the darkness literally um in a
lot of ways. This was
a uh um a homeschool group that does
their stuff online. These students are
from all over the country, even
different parts of the world, but
they're all like,
>> I don't know, elementary school up to
middle school maybe.
>> It's called um Inhome Academy. And so
I've had the privilege to be able to
share with them every Monday of a
certain month. Uh twice now, I think two
or three times, actually three times,
three years in a row,
>> I've gotten to share
uh every Monday of a certain month and
get to share with these kids. That was
awesome.
>> I believe it's based in Alaska, the inh
home academy.
>> No,
>> you mentioned that. I think you're
getting that confused with the another
one. Yeah,
>> there's a church from Alaska that has
invited me to share over Zoom,
>> but this lady Muriel, she actually is
>> local to us.
>> Um, we got to go to Hawaii.
>> Aahu.
>> Aahu. Hawaii. Now, this is pretty cool
because God just works.
>> You know, we actually didn't get to have
a honeymoon when we got married. And so
>> we went off to a a
what was it? A camperee
or
something right after we got married.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah.
>> So I had
>> hours after we got married.
>> I had to speak at a prayer conference
the day after we got married. So
>> y
>> um this was months later.
>> We decided, you know what? We're gonna
go to Hawaii. And Aubrey had been many
times in her life. I'd never been. And
we went, we visited the church and God
opened up the doors and I got to share
with the youth three days in a row.
>> So, right after church here, I got to
go. They were having a called Yeah.
Pathfinders Adventures.
>> And I got to share the book. This is
Aby's Strange Dreams book.
>> And you know, they put a shell necklace
on you or something when you when you
come to the church there. And here's a
video of me doing a reading.
>> Some people just like uh somebody a
stranger will say, "Hey, I got some
candy for you. You want some candy? You
take that candy from a stranger?"
>> So, I'm basically saying you can't just
trust, you know, strangers. So, why
would you trust an alien or an angel or
a ghost or something like that? And so I
don't have pictures of what happened
after that, but the next day I got to
share with a small group of youth like
older people, you know, like uh high
schoolers. And then the next day again
with some other high schoolers. So
that's just how God works, you know.
It's like
>> you go on vacation or have a honeymoon
and God opens the doors for you to speak
three times. And that again, it was
unpaid. you know, we just doing this
because we love sharing the truth with
people. And that was some kids that
wanted autographs. Um,
I'm going to I'm going to look over here
so I can see if we're missing any good
chats or anything.
Uh,
each and every month I'm short. $550.
Y'all is getting a family member to send
help randomly. The money sent is never
enough to heat my place though. Y'all,
>> please turn your face towards me. Yes,
>> I know, man. We are there's so many
people going through so many hard things
right now and um Kim, we will definitely
keep you in prayer about that because we
get a lot of prayer requests often. And
so,
>> what was it?
>> It says you guys are cutting out a bit.
>> We're cutting out a bit. Wait, our
picture or the audio?
>> Two people, AD and Serenity said that.
>> Is it audio? Am I the only one seeing
this?
>> H
>> go.
>> Seeing or hearing?
>> Sounds good. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
this is actually me speaking at a
nursing home.
My mom before she passed away, she went
to a hospital for a week and then they
put her in a nursing home for a week and
that's where she passed away.
>> And I got acquainted with the lady there
that she
she orchestrates everything for these
people to have something to do like all
over the calendar. And a lot of it is
Bible studies and people coming, you
know, they have like game night bingo
and all this stuff.
But I got to go share some presentations
with this nursing home
uh four or five times and that was a
blessing. You know, that was where my
mom was very short time. I mean, she
didn't get to meet anybody. She was not
in her right mind and she was uh
literally
dying at that point. But, you know, God
places us everywhere for a reason. And
so I got to come and share
a presentation about the power of
intercessory prayer, about claiming
God's promises to people who are stuck
in this nursing home all the time. And
and they don't have much hope, you know,
and so God got to send me in there, you
know. I'm I'm in my early 40s. I just
turned 42,
but I still feel like compared to them,
like this young guy comes in and he's
sharing the word of God and, you know,
spending time with them. And so that was
a blessing.
Let me see what else we got here. Um,
it's been a busy busy year, guys. What's
going on here, Aubrey?
>> I spoke on health, specifically hormone
disruptors called xenoestrogens in
Shelbyville, Indiana.
And that was all weekend long. And it
was good. A lot of people were
definitely wanting answers to health um
problems and
it was intense speaking every single day
for quite a few hours. But
>> yeah,
>> it was wonderful.
>> So she says it like hormone disruptors.
It sounds kind of
>> vague if you don't know, but this is
actually a really good presentation
because it talks about all the things in
your home that are that we use every
day, things that we buy from the store,
things that we like, scented candles and
things like that and products, all kinds
of products that the chemicals in them
are altering your genetics. They're
altering your u your hormones
>> and men are getting man boobs and women
are having menstrual crazy
>> off-the-wall menstrual cycles and um
>> and cancer is the result usually or
several progressions of diseases and uh
other things.
>> Yep.
>> Before cancer but then you go there.
Yeah.
>> I keep telling her to give this lecture.
Linda Yes. I keep telling her to do this
on our channel because
>> and Carol
>> knows it. I gave it at um what was the
name of
>> International Truth Expo.
>> Yep.
>> Which we'll be showing some of that. So
>> Mhm.
>> Yes. I'll make Aubrey give this
presentation on our channel because it
is it's a grand conspiracy. These
companies,
you know, it's the love of money is
Rudolph evil. They put these chemicals
in these products a lot of times so they
have a longer shelf life.
Uh this was a random youth group that I
got invited to um to share my testimony.
Again, this was a really cool thing.
Every week these kids, this is awesome.
Like every week these kids on their own
come to this house and and they have a
guest speaker come.
>> So these are actually college kids.
>> College kids. Yeah. What did I say?
>> Just youth group kind of gives the idea
of high schoolers.
>> Yeah. So they're all college.
And
here was a cool opportunity.
>> Yep. This is in Colorado. This lady here
>> was really well known on HGTV. Her name
is Carrie.
>> She had her own show on Home Garden
Network. I guess HGTV is what it's
called.
>> And she left HGTV
because this is awesome. I love stories
like this. She's like an insider, you
know, she was in there.
>> She became a Christian or maybe was a
Christian for a while, but um HGTV was
trying to get her, bless you, was trying
to get her to compromise on some things.
You know, TV knows that sex sells and
all this. And she'd said, she said, um,
you know, sometimes they'd be like, "Oh,
we want you to like ride up on a
motorcycle in a bikini or something."
And she's like, "No, what are you
doing?" and like this is. So she left.
She had a great job making great money,
had fame and left because she didn't
want to compromise her Christian morals.
>> And so she started her own podcast. You
guys should check it out. It's called uh
Gritty Glory and Gritty Glory with Car
Kerianne on YouTube. Check her out. Um,
she interviews people for their
testimonies and things and it's really
cool and that was a good experience we
got to have.
This was cool. We got to be on Strange
Normal. I can't believe my shirt is so
torn. You can see my armpit
>> in there. See, we need your support so I
can buy clothes without holes in it. Um,
but really um,
>> somebody say good for her. That's That
woman's hair is perfect. Yeah, she's
probably used to having hair and
wardrobe and learned a thing or two.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh, greedy glory, somebody said.
>> Mhm.
>> Looking through the comments here.
Aubrey gave a great presentation at the
International Truth Expo.
>> He put on a great
>> expo. I mean, it was amazing. That was
four days. Like, most of the time it's
just like a Saturday, Sunday or
something. This was four days we got to
hang out and it was so cool. Somebody
just said, uh, oh, I just finished
watching video about someone saying,
"Stop using items." Yeah, people are
starting to wake up
>> about stuff. So, we were on Strange
Normal. If you haven't checked out
Brad's channel, go to uh YouTube,
Strange Normal, and he's always updating
on this whole
alien agenda, the paranormal inter. He
just interviewed a missionary named
David Gates who's been all over the
world. He's a pilot and he's seen a lot
of crazy stuff. Uh but yeah, definitely
go check out Brad's channel, Strange
Normal. We'll be
>> hanging out with him tomorrow actually.
>> Um this missionary actually has a TV
station in Bolivia that we spoke at or
Mikey spoke at. We have pictures that
are coming up of that as well.
>> Somebody says, "I love Bradley." So,
there's a
>> there's a good promotion right there.
Um, we went to this church
>> in California, Fresno.
>> What is it called? Uh,
>> Oros or Rosi.
>> Seventh Day Church of Revelation.
>> Can't keep them all straight. So, you
got to take pictures of the bulletins.
>> Deceiving the world. I got to share
about this alien deception
at this uh event. There's And then
Aubrey, look at this. Aubrey was there
>> on Who is the Rainman? If you guys
haven't seen that presentation, go check
it out on our channel.
>> It's about bail worship and it was quite
powerful.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. It's always kind of awkward when
you get into that stuff because people
just they have no clue
>> Yeah.
>> how deep and dark all this stuff is that
we we participate in when we listen to
these bands and rappers and stuff. So
there's the Cand of Truth logo on the
laptop.
>> That's that church. Yeah.
>> Yeah. This is the same church. You see
her presentation over here.
>> Baffitz. Yeah.
>> You got um
>> Rihanna.
>> Rihanna in her umbrella video.
>> And Aubry is doing her thing up there
looking beautiful while she does it.
This was in Chicago. We were hanging out
with Aillaa from School for Profits. If
you don't know about School for Profits,
go subscribe. Yeah. school for prophets.
That's prophets like a biblical prophet,
not like cash money prophet.
>> And uh I'm wearing one of his hats here
that says kingdom on it. But this was uh
at the church. They did a showing for a
documentary that he made called the
second coming documentary
>> that Mikey was in.
>> Yep. It was an all-star cast. I mean, it
had a bunch of big hitters in there,
preachers and stuff. And I was blessed
to be able to be a part of that. And in
there, I'm talking about the truth of
what happens when you die.
>> The truth about the rapture, when it
really happens, how it's actually the
second coming, not a pre-tribulation
rapture.
>> I'm trying to keep an eye on the chat a
little bit. How many people are in here?
We got 50 people in here. Thank you guys
so much for being in here. Do you sell
bumper stickers? We don't have bumper
stickers. We got stickers, though.
>> Um,
>> actually, you know what?
>> I wanted to do a little
>> giveaway.
>> A little giveaway. We got 50 people in
here. So, we have a friend in Australia.
She came up with an idea to make a game
called I Know Him. It's like Uno.
>> Exactly like Uno.
>> Exactly like it. But it's super fun.
It's got every every card has a
scripture on there. And all the cards
are based on um like bad things like
>> sins and temptations that will come at
you,
>> right? And so you'll read a card like
this.
>> Yeah. Let me show you this real quick
again. So materialism
and when you put it down has a Bible
verse to read that takes care of that.
It talks about it.
Um Matthew 6:19-21.
Do not lay up for yourselves treasures
on earth where moth and rust destroy and
where thieves break in and steal. But
lay up for yourselves treasures in
heaven. for where your treasure is,
there your heart will be also. So, she
just made this and this is amazing.
>> Yeah, they're super cool.
>> I mean, I I like Uno, so it was really
good.
>> And you know, you have like a a
repentance card. There's um there's a
shield card that blocks you from the
temptation,
>> from attacks, actually. Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, this is super cool. If you
like Uno, you're going to love this
because every card has a Bible verse on
it and it's a fun way to read. And you
know, my daughter even like one time
once or twice I like forgot to read it
and she was like, "You didn't read the
verse." And so it, you know, even kids
are excited to hear the Bible verse. And
so I have a brand new sealed version
here
>> that she gave me all the way from
Australia. And I want to give one away
to you guys. I'm trying to think of what
to do to make it like what what do we do
to
>> send it
>> give it away to somebody.
>> Um,
basically, let's see what's like a
question we can ask or something.
>> I'm trying to think of like a trivia
question. We'll we'll we'll be thinking
about I want to give this away to
somebody and whoever answers the trivia
question can mail us or email us your
address
>> and we'll mail you that. Also,
>> you know, I'm want to just promote stuff
here because we talk a lot about things
that are not good for you and so we want
to have replacements like this. And
also, if you never heard of um
Forerunner, Chris Hudson, 4Runner
Chronicles, let me see if I can find him
real quick. Forerunner
Chronicles.
Um, if you've never heard of this guy,
he has some amazing, powerful videos.
He's been doing this for a long time,
exposing. He went to the Vatican and was
uh right there taking video and exposing
what it all was and talking about how
the Vatican is the beast system and
stuff.
>> But he literally just came out with an
app and I'm encouraging you guys. I've
already been sharing this thing on our
social media. It's right here called
Kingdom Climb. This is a a picture of
it.
And yeah, actually on his Instagram,
he's got some video of it. I don't want
to have to sign in. Really?
>> Yeah, it is.
>> Oh, come on.
>> He wants that.
>> Wait, where did he go? Um, Kingdom
Climb. It is $6.99. Okay, so
it this is an amazing game. It's all
handdrawn. None of it's AI. It's
handdrawn. He had a whole team helping
him. The the music is amazing. The game
play is amazing.
>> Well, let's talk about why it's
important. It's all about memorizing
scripture.
>> Yes.
So, yeah, the whole game. Look, look at
this. This animation. Okay. So,
>> this is the game that you're seeing it
right here.
>> So, you jump on pigs heads. You collect
these coins. You collect scrolls that
have scriptures on them. And every game
you have to memorize a scripture. shows
you a scripture at the beginning, like
say it's John 3:16,
um, a pig will vacuum up three of the
words out of that scripture, and you
have to memorize which words because
along the way, you're going to be faced
with which of these three words was one
of them that was taken, and if you get
it wrong, you got to start over,
whatever.
>> So, yes, it is $6.99.
Let's support our Christian content
creators, please. Like it bothers me to
no end when people are like this should
be free. You're trying to, you know,
profit off of the word of God and all
this stuff. This guy spent no telling
how much money trying to get this app
out there so that people can have a fun
way to memorize scripture and get your
kids involved. This is an amazing game.
I've played I've been playing it with my
daughter and I can't get enough of it.
It's super fun. Look at this. I'll show
this video again, but please seven
bucks, $6.99. I actually saved $2 by, I
don't know, something popped up and said
save two bucks. But, you know, $7,
that's like a fast food combo or
something, right? This is going to be
way more beneficial than something like
that. And it's a one-time payment and
you're going to have this game forever.
So, I did want to promote his thing
because it's it's almost in the top 20.
>> That's why he's trying to push people to
buy it right now because it's almost in
the top 20 of the games on on the Play
Store.
>> So,
this You want to talk about this? This
was at the Ark Encounter in Kentucky
and we were helping out with that event
with the kids and
yes, we were at the the flat earth
conference in Arizona.
>> Although it wasn't a flat earth
conference.
>> Yeah, it wasn't actually
>> the International Truth Expo.
>> That's what it was called. But yeah, at
the Ark encounter, we were able to meet
lots of good people and work on their
team and we were at that for uh world,
what is it called?
>> What? Oh,
>> wisdom wisdom.
>> Pearl is the guy who put it on and he
puts on lots of good conferences for
information
>> and so
um he does them all the time and so we
were just privileged to be a part of it.
The name of the game is Kingdom Climb.
>> You can look it up on the, you know,
iTunes or the Play Store, whatever that
your phone takes. But I have it on my
phone. It's awesome. I got it on my
daughter's phone. Kingdom Climb is so
fun. So, yeah, this Wisdom Pearl thing
was called AI in the Days of Noah. So,
they're like, "Let's have it at the Ark.
We're talking about the days of Noah."
And it was a miracle how it even
happened. They said nobody who's outside
of the Ark Encounter
members get to speak in this main
auditorium.
>> And our friend, our personal friend who
has a ministry called Wisdom Pearl is
the first person outside of the Answers
in Genesis members to speak in that room
and they almost didn't let it happen. It
It was a miracle.
>> A lot of spiritual warfare that they
would didn't want to let him have that
room.
>> Yep. And we got to for like two or three
days, two days, I guess,
>> um, teach the kids. I got to share the
book with them. We got to do some, uh,
>> discernment exercises.
>> Yeah. There was a game called Sheep or
Goat, and we shared clips from even
Christian cartoons that were in error.
Like there's a Christian cartoon that
shows
uh, the creation story
>> and the fish jump out onto land and turn
into tigers, all kinds of stuff. And it
was so fun to see how smart these kids
are because they're like, "That's not
true." and all that stuff. So that was
awesome. U so that was fun. We did that
this year. Um Aubrey and I ended up in
Washington DC. You can see the
>> Yep. White House there.
>> Whatever that is, the Capitol building.
>> Oh yeah, actually that's probably true.
>> So how' this happen?
>> Um
we were going to Florida and we were
rerouted. Our flight got delayed.
>> We were coming back home from Florida.
>> Yeah. To come home from Florida. And it
got delayed up to like five times, I
believe. Five or six times. And they
just decided they were going to cancel
it. And then we were stuck.
And that this was in North Carolina, I
think. Am I remembering that right?
>> What?
>> That we were stuck there.
>> North Carolina or something like that.
>> No. Yeah. And then they said, "Well, the
only flight we have back to Chattanooga
is
>> like two days.
>> Two days from now. So, you're going to
we're going to have to send you to
Washington and put you in a hotel that
time period so that we can fly you back
to Chattanooga."
And so, we ended up in Washington
against I would say against my will
because I really don't love it there
because of the spiritual darkness in
Washington.
And we just felt impressed that if we're
here, God must be putting us here to go
cover the paganism within our
government.
And so we did, we have that video.
>> What is crazy is we did we got to show
we got to do a whole breakdown exposing
how there's so many false gods in that
building by name. They're literally
written on the wall. Apollo, Zeus, all
of it. Uh Manurva, uh literally Zeus is
outside. It's not really Zeus. Neptune.
A big old statue of Neptune is right out
front and it tells you on a plaque who
it is
>> and we're told this is a Christian
nation. We exposed the whole thing and
when we got back So when we flew from
Washington DC back to Oh, so we got to
the airport in Washington DC to figure
out where we're going to go next. They
flew us right back to North Carolina,
the same exact airport that sent us to
Washington DC and then sent us to
Chattanooga. And I was like, why would
an airport say, "We're going to send you
home in 2 days, but you have to go to
Washington DC just to send us right back
to the very same airport." It makes no
sense.
>> They should have said, "We're going to
put you in a hotel right here in North
Carolina because two days from now,
you're going to fly out from here."
>> None of it made sense. We just knew it
was like,
>> "We're God's putting you here."
>> Yep.
>> You you're just being rerouted. And so I
I'll show a quick little short we have
that we did of that that I really like.
>> The individual is handicapped by coming
face to face with a conspiracy so
monstrous that he cannot believe it even
exists.
>> And the truth coming at you with the
truth. And look where we're at. Our
nation's capital.
>> All the symbolism behind us. All kinds
of stuff on the ceiling. I never thought
I'd see so much like just in your face
stuff likees,
compasses, sun motif everywhere, even
the names of false gods. And yet people
think that this country was founded on
Christianity. We're about to show you
that's not true. Here we are, Washington
DC, the obelisk.
Why do we have an obelisk in America?
>> We're going to find out.
>> Man, that was so good. We have all the
evidence needed to prove. But
>> truth be told, the whole time we were
there, I was almost
spiritually
oppressed the whole time. It felt so
dark
>> and I hated every minute of it. Um,
it was just bad. I was very depressed.
>> Yep. But, you know, God puts us in some
tough places sometimes. What is up?
Jeremiahkea in the building. Much love
to you and your wife because I was just
about to talk about this. So, we
we don't have pictures in here for some
reason, but um
>> I forgot that one.
>> It was spiritual warfare putting these
pictures together. Every picture I used
was like a broken I had to convert them
in Photoshop.
>> Corrupted file, it said.
>> Yeah. So,
I said at the beginning of this that I
prayed that God would put us into
places that were outside the church. And
in Kansas, again, speaking of uh the Ark
Encounter, in Kansas was a
a conference called Spiracy Con. And it
was a weekend conference with a lot of
Christian conspiracy theorists talking
about everywhere, everything from
Bigfoot to aliens. and I got to talk
about um the satanic themes in Hollywood
movies and
yeah, so that happened. We got to go to
that. That was put on by Now You See TV.
That happened. Then a month later, I
think I was at Truther Con 2025. 2025
that Jeremiah put on right here. That
was an amazing event. got to see a lot
of people that uh I never met before
that I look up to. It was super cool
event. Awesome. Cool stage with a big
LED screen that had an ending with
Bryson.
I can't even remember his name. I don't
keep up with uh music too much, but he
Bryson Gray. He was super good uh
Christian rapper guy. And then shortly
after that, like another month later,
got to speak at International Truth Expo
in Courtsite, Arizona, put on by Carol
with a K, who is also in this chat right
now.
>> So, here's a picture of us. You can't
really see. We're trying to get these
big mountainous
>> Arizona.
>> Arizona rocks in the back. You can't see
it behind us, but here's Aubrey looking
beautiful, giving her presentation about
the xenoestrogens again, the products to
avoid and stuff. There's a better
picture of the stage. I don't you didn't
give it to me. But
>> I didn't see it. I must have sent it to
you and then something happened. This
event was awesome because Carol with a
K, this was her first time ever putting
on an event and she's like, I don't know
how this is all going to work out, but
she just prayed and started reaching out
to people including us and some amazing
speakers and it all worked out and
everybody flew out to this place in
Arizona and we just had a great time. We
were there four days.
>> We got to see a lot of cool booths, hear
a lot of cool presentations. We got to
hang out by a fire pit and just get to
know each other better.
>> And that's where we met
uh Mark Sergeant and DJ, who by the way,
we're going to be on their channel in 45
minutes.
>> Yeah. So, tonight, if you're still up,
still want to hang out with us, go check
out Mark Sergeant's channel. It's called
Strange World is the is the podcast. and
we're going to be hanging out with them
and I we'll have links in our social
media.
>> So, that was a super cool event.
>> We also came across and ended up
adopting a flying squirrel.
>> Yeah, this is just something for fun.
But, you know, everything we do in our
life, it takes up time. We have a a cute
little cat. Every time we travel, we
hire my dad to watch our house and watch
the cat and at the time watch the
squirrel before we got to set him free.
But we had him for two months.
>> Mhm.
>> Two months. This little baby. Check this
out.
>> I don't know what this is exactly.
>> I didn't,
>> but it's so sweet.
>> We found him
>> here at Foster Falls.
>> Is he just drinking?
She's licking.
>> She might be licking it. Yeah,
>> he's licking the
filthy.
>> This is like a pet. Maybe it was
>> Oh, let's see. Uh Lindsay, what's up?
Great having you at Truther Con this
year. Such great truth you spread. Thank
you so much. You guys did amazing. Um,
you and Jeremiah, I know it was your
first time putting on event and it just
turned out so great. You guys are a
great team. You have a
uh together you come together with your
creativity and your orchestrate, what's
it called? Your structure and all that
stuff.
>> Finding an organization I heard was
great.
>> Yeah. So, this little guy um we went
swimming at this waterfall and I was
climbing a rock to jump in and he popped
out of a hole and I was like, whoa. Kind
of freaked out like there's a rodent up
here and I didn't know what it was and
and but I realized he was very tame. He
wasn't afraid of me and I and he wasn't
trying to hurt me or anything.
>> He said he was soaked too. Yeah, he's
he's wet here. And uh so I coaxed him
into my hat, brought him over there, and
found out he's super friendly. And he
got in Aubrey's hoodie
>> right after that event. He was
>> Aubrey's got a little surprise in her
hood back here. What do we got?
>> Hey, little guy. Oh, look at him.
digging on your back.
>> What?
>> He's digging on your back.
>> Digging.
>> Actually really miss him because we
built a house for him. Put him on the
Put him on the tree. He It was all this
natural progression. Um we had a box for
him. It had a heater under it. We
started feeding him with a bottle, but
he didn't want the bottle, so we fed him
granola and nuts and things, and he just
ate it right up. Mhm.
>> And he eventually would get in our hand
and I'd hold my hand up and he would
leap from my hand into his box and he'd
run back to do it again. Like he wanted
to be picked up and leap and he'd spread
out his wings. We got video of it, too.
But
>> and he is a flying squirrel. Yes, I can
confirm that.
>> Yep. He's a flying squirrel
>> and we had lots of fun. Um
but yeah, he was turned loose and so we
haven't seen him in a while.
>> Yeah. So, one night I was going live and
right when I ended the live, it was
late. I mean, it was like 1:00 a.m. and
I heard something going on in the box
and I looked and he was just going nuts.
Like he sometimes he would like, you
know, he's nocturnal, so he crawl around
in his box at night and stuff, but he
was like hurting himself like trying to
get out of there, which he never did
before, ever. Actually, I'd open the box
and he just kind of looked around. He
didn't try to escape ever.
>> But when I opened the box, he was just
like like jumped right on me. It was
running around my body all over my head
and everything. And I was like, I think
he's ready to go out. And so we had a
house built for him. And I put it on the
tree that night at like 1:00 in the
morning. And um he zipped off. And then
the next morning I went out there and
saw him in his little hammock. We put a
hammock, a a blanket, a kids blanket,
like a baby blanket, hammock, and he was
in there. And we'd get to feed him, and
he'd lick on our finger. He'll hold your
finger with both hands and just lick it.
And for two days, he was in there in and
out. And now I haven't seen him in a
while because we read that when you put
them in a house like that, they'll stay
there temporarily, but then their
natural instincts come in and they want
to make their own home, and they make
multiple homes. So, he's out there
having a blast. Jeremiah says, "Keep it
up, guys. Thank you so much. We we
appreciate all the love and support,
man. And it's been cool getting to
crossromote on your show." And
um I just can't thank you guys enough
for supporting us this whole time,
whether it's financially or just
clicking that thumbs up or sharing it or
just giving us comments because
>> we're so encouraged by the comments we
get. I want to share another little
picture here.
I know this this isn't, you know, this
is just for fun. The little squirrel guy
doesn't really have much to do with our
ministry except
>> that we are saving lives out here, even
little squirrel lives.
>> And he was going to die. There's no If
we would have left him there, if I would
not have climbed that rock at that time,
nobody would have found him. He would
have had nowhere to go except back in
the water and in a hole in the wall. Uh
what happened was he fell out of a nest
that was 40 feet above us into the water
and he was stuck on the rock.
>> And so we raised him for two months to
the point where he gets to be have his
own little home out here now.
>> He let me give him massages.
>> Yeah.
>> And here in a second you'll see our cat
in the video which
>> is it this one?
>> Yeah. The screen turns around. You see
the cat?
A
>> sweet boy.
Let's see. Oh, see we're getting all
kinds of This is the type of stuff video
can't be played because the file is
corrupt. It's not corrupt. We were just
watching it. Anyway, get thee behind me,
Satan. This is the squirrel on my head.
>> He was such a fun guy.
>> Oh, look at that little A. He was always
licking, so
that's what he was doing.
>> A, that's so cute.
>> All right, so here are some very
encouraging
comments that have come in over since we
started this ministry.
>> And there were a lot more, by the way,
but we just didn't have time. We really
put this together in a few, you know, 30
minutes, apart from all of the
interruptions of
>> Yeah.
you know, file corruption and and kind
of spiritual tax along the way of trying
to put this together.
>> Yeah. Do you want to read some of these,
babe?
>> Sure.
>> Talking.
>> It says on the truth about death and
afterlife video, someone said, "Thank
you for this well put together Bible
study. I too was taught absent from the
body, present with the Lord, but the
scriptures you used make sense. You're
definitely helping me in reading
scripture to understand it for myself
and not through a lens of what others
teach you. Thank you.
>> Amen.
This was one on hell. Your church lied
about hell. And the comment says, "Wow,
thank you so much for sharing.
Definitely makes a lot of sense." Now,
here's another one.
>> It says, "I took so many notes watching
this. Thank you for creating this
video."
See, that's that's really what we want
to do. We don't want to be the source of
truth. We don't want to be like, "We
said it so it's true." We want to make
you think outside of the traditional box
and to dig deeper. And so, I always say,
"Fact check me. Don't just trust me. I'm
telling you what I've come to know, but
fact check me because I want you to
think
it's cool to think. You know, that's
what the whole point of the the our logo
is
>> that it's a man wearing sunglasses,
which represents being cool or whatever,
and you see his brain.
>> It's cool to think. And we need to stop
just buying into everything because it's
told to us on the news or because the
church told us our whole life or
whatever. We need to think outside the
box and start thinking for ourselves.
And so these these were very encouraging
to see these comments.
>> Mhm.
It says, "Thank you once again for an
eyeopening video. Thanks for putting the
time and work into this so that we could
understand. I have never been taught
this and it sure does make a whole lot
of things make sense."
>> If you haven't seen these videos, check
it out. It's what happens when you die
and the truth about hell. These are
vital important to me. Like these are
things that push people away from the
church when they don't understand the
truth about it because it makes God look
like a a tyrant who says bow to me or
burn for eternity, which it's it's not
true.
>> And so I'd love for you guys to check
those videos out. Um
I'm looking at some of the messages
here. I see. Bro, next time you're at
Truth or Con, you gotta meet our three
cats. Yeah, dude. All about some kitty
cats.
>> Um, let's see what other
Wow. Just finished listening and I'm
going to listen again. This was actually
about the hell one, I think, or the what
happens when you die. I think it was the
hell one, though. Just finished
listening. I'm going to listen again and
share with my husband. You really have
me thinking, Mikey. Thank you and God
bless.
Um, this one was about alcohol, what the
Bible says about alcohol. If you haven't
seen this one, it's a really good study
because I actually learned more about
the topic as I was putting this
together, but um, this was a good
comment.
>> Yeah. And they said, "I am disappointed
that you're right. I'm convicted or
convinced and will no longer drink
alcohol. No more homemade mead for me."
M and I said, "Praise the Lord. The
truth will make you free. People really
fight for this because they love the
feeling. Sin does feel good, but it
doesn't make it right and will lead to
death and destruction." Look, I come
from
being an alcoholic, a pthead,
fornicator, rapper, all the things that
feel good to the flesh lead to death and
destruction. And God is never keeping
anything good from us. But he is
protecting us. These things destroy your
mind, your families, your body. Um they
destroy you physically and spiritually.
>> And
you know, for people to hold on and say,
"Well, it's not bad if I just do a
little bit of it." All these things lead
to worse things, you know.
>> And here was uh here was one here. It
says, "I'm so so grateful that y'all
made this video teaching."
>> This is about the alcohol one, too, by
the way.
>> Right. Because before I watched it, I
was under the impression that alcoholic
wine was the type in the Bible. And I
have many times repeated the saying in
moderation. But after listening to all
the evidence and reason that y'all
brought in this episode, it's obvious. I
already rarely drink drank alcohol and
never enough to get drunk because I
learned in my early adulthood that being
drunk was not good. But I'm glad at age
>> to finally know the full truth now. So I
can walk almost sorry I can walk always
more narrowly on the path. Aba is so
good to guide us and light our path when
we seek and love his truth. Hallelujah.
Thanks again for sharing. I know this
teaching will be a blessing to many. no
doubt will change lives.
>> Amen.
So, that was the last slide we had, but
>> that's where we've been this year.
>> And not all of it. There there's things
we don't even have pictures of. I
>> There's been zooms. There's been, you
know, I don't even take pictures most of
the time. I had to remind myself like,
"Oh, I should take some pictures just
for our our audience and stuff to see
that we don't just sit around in our
PJs,
you know, scrolling around on the
internet like, what could we do a video
about today?" I think it's it's easy to
fall into that belief that you see a
YouTuber and you're like, man, these
people just get paid to just like get on
a video and talk about whatever they
want to talk about.
>> It's not easy. I mean, there are times
that we just feel exhausted, like
mentally, spiritually drained, like,
man, I just need a week off or
something. And it,
>> you know, somebody might think that's
like laughable, like, a week off? What
do you mean? You work from home and all
this stuff.
>> We're always going, you guys. We don't
really get time off.
>> Yeah. It's hard to even get time with
each other.
>> And we travel so much that it's it's
always a constant struggle.
So, and we don't usually when we're
saying that, you guys saw when we
actually took the trip for a honeymoon,
but we don't just take that week off, we
actually push through it. Um
>> Oh, yeah. We still are doing we're still
working.
>> And so, it's just kind of like, man,
it's But Satan comes against you. He
really is discouraging. He dishart makes
you disheartened. And
so we have we've had a lot of uh
spiritual warfare going on.
>> I don't want to forget about the
giveaway. I'm still I still don't know
what to do exactly, but we should do
some kind of trivia. Uh I'd love for
this to go to somebody that's got kids
or maybe they somebody that is all into
like doing family game night or
something
>> because it's really awesome. And so
what could we
do a trivia on?
>> I don't know. I could get really hard on
people with my
>> my presentations and quiz you up and
down.
>> Yeah.
>> But I don't think I should do that.
>> You know what? Um
I don't know. Whoever whoever can put in
the chat
uh
I don't know
well if we need we can take some more
time but we have been this obviously is
what we've been kind of winding up to
it's on thumbnail what we where we're
going and where we're going is that we
have been fe uh feeling like were
been called to
go ahead and get
um some land. God has been calling us to
have a school
and some other things. You want to talk
about that?
>> Yeah. So, we we talk about living in
Chattanooga, but we really live on the
outskirts. It's kind of in the country,
but it's not enough in the country. And
I do feel like,
>> and just so you guys know, you know,
when we talk about making our mortgage
and stuff, we have a a humble home. I
would turn this thing around and show
you, but um we,
you know, we feel that we need to be in
the country more,
>> that we need to buy some land and put
homes on that land. You know, not not
necessarily tiny homes, but homes that
are easy to build. They're called
modular homes. They come to you in giant
pieces that can just be put up quick.
And we want to put homes out there for
our family and extended brothers in
Christ and family for these last days
that are coming. We want to be able to
grow our own food, have our own water.
And we found
>> online we see property that's not too
far from us, but it's actually near that
waterfall that we showed you. It's up on
the mountain and it's got a stream
running through it. It looks pretty much
flat
>> and it seems to be big enough and it's
definitely like affordable. It's
definitely in an affordable range. It's
not expensive
>> and we're going to be seeing it
hopefully this week or next week.
>> Yeah. And so we do feel the call to
start our own church up there to have a
a school that's like a last last days
preparation training school where people
can come
>> stay for a week or something. We haven't
figured all the details out on that yet,
but it'll be like kind of like a week
training camp
>> where people learn how to live off the
grid, how to uh get water when there's
no water around, how to get things that
you can edible plants or how to take
care of uh bandage up a wound or
whatever things that when you get hurt,
how to fix those things.
>> And so, um, somebody said do a video of
it. Mhm.
>> So, what we're asking is, we know this
isn't a message for everyone, but if you
are a wealthy person watching this and
you feel called by God to support a
ministry and you want to talk to us more
or whatever you need to do, we just
we're we're putting out there what we're
up to.
>> We want to do a lot more things. We want
to produce more kids books. We're
already working on the second one. I
wish I would have showed pictures of
that.
>> Yep. Maybe I can show pictures of that.
>> But yeah, God is calling us to expand.
And we also have not been able to we
lost the person that we had doing
social media for us. Um and we have a
very
>> That sounds bad. Our our social media
person
>> had other plans,
>> moved on to what they were going to
school for. We were just a temporary
thing.
>> Yeah. And so um anyway, we we do need to
be able to hire people. So, we have we
have needs um
is the only way I know how to put it.
>> This is the second book. By the way, we
do have a Patreon. patreon.com if you
guys want to give monthly.
>> Um we, you know, we don't really put
anything. We don't put anything on here
that costs money. You know, people
always think you're trying to sell
something. Everything on here is free.
Anyone can look at this right now. Um I
know people that say, "Oh, you know, I
feel like I'm missing out because I
can't pay." This is free. Go to our go
to our Patreon and just look at it.
Everything's available to be seen. This
is actually our our garden.
>> Come with us in the garden.
>> Let's see.
>> Mikey is going to help.
>> It was an entire cucumber. All cucumbers
>> um walk through of the whole garden. So,
I'm not sure that we need to show all of
it, but
>> we will always be trying to do a garden
and keep up with it while we travel. I'm
I'm a gardener. I have to.
>> I need to. This is the second book that
my daughter is actually doing the
artwork for. This is her own characters,
Gooey and Shadow. A orange silly cat
named Gooey, a black serious cat named
Shadow. And basically, they best
friends. They do everything together.
They're riding skateboards together
here.
And this is all rough right now, but
>> they're playing tag here. Um, let me
zoom in on this.
So, of course.
>> Yeah,
>> of course. Anyway, um they're playing
tag
and they run past an alleyway and
there's something glowing and it catches
Shadow's attention and he reaches out
for something and it's, you know,
something like a a tarot card deck or
something
>> and he's gets real intrigued by this um
occult thing. And so he starts hanging
out with the wrong crowd. He's playing
violent video games. And you see here,
Gooey is lonely. He's riding his bike by
himself. His friend isn't on the bench
with him. His friend's not helping him
play baseball. He was teaching him play
baseball before that.
>> And now here's his friend with this
violent video game in his hand. And he's
like, "Hey, we should play this." And
Gooy's like, "No, I don't think we
should." And so he gets mad and storms
off. You're no fun. you're, you know,
you're lame. And it shows him playing
with some tarot cards. He's playing, you
know, watching things on this tablet
that he shouldn't be watching. Hanging
out with new friends now. And these
friends are all kind of, you know, like
a snake. And
>> they're spiritually dark.
>> Yeah. And here's Gooey seeing his friend
go down this bad road. And so Gooey
starts praying for his friend Shadow.
And Shadow's in his room with his skull
poster that says, "Don't judge." under
there. and he's listening to bad music
on his iPhone and uh he starts having
these encounters. These are three
frames. You see these uh shadowy hands
grabbing at him and he's looking scared
>> and these shadowy things are flying
around the room and he remembers what
his grandma told him that anytime you
get scared cry out to Jesus. And so he
says, "Jesus, help me." and a bright
light beams in and you see these things
scatter off and he feels so ashamed.
He's saying, you know, it says sin and
sin. He's saying, "Please, I'm so
sorry." And he feels ashamed and he
feels like he's not going to be accepted
by God. But Jesus reaches down and lifts
his head up. And
so now he's going back to um his friend.
He still feels ashamed, feels like his
friend's not going to accept him.
>> Uh, a scene that's not in here is he
throw throws away all his stuff in the
trash,
>> all the bad games and stuff.
>> And here he is, he sees his friend
playing basketball with all these other
friends. And there's even one in a
wheelchair and one with a walker. My
daughter's always being inclusive with
special needs people.
And um, he comes to him and he says he's
sorry and will you ever forgive me? And
Gooey, you know, gives him a big old hug
because he's been praying for this very
moment that his friend would repent of
these things and come back. And and so
now all the friends are embracing Gooey
and Shadow together. You can see the
wheelchair here, the back of the
wheelchair. And um here Shadow is
sharing his testimony somewhere and he's
sharing what happened to him and Guy's
talking about how he prayed for his
friend and all that. And in the crowd is
are those mean friends, those bad
friends. And this one here
>> is receiving what he's saying and he
wants to become a Christian too. And so
you see him join them and he becomes a
Christian and that's the end of the
story. So it's basically the prodical
son story, but it's like the prodical
friend and it teaches about intercessory
prayer. It teaches about staying away
from bad things that you shouldn't be
messing with that it invites
>> demons in. Mhm.
>> And forgiveness. So all of that wrapped
in one. And that's that is the book. And
thank you so much, Jeremiah. Yes. Click
the like button. It is free. And great
to see people be inclusive. Yep. My
daughter's always including
different races. And you know, our first
book was a little black girl. For one,
she's
minority and female. So, we're always
trying to include people that feel
excluded.
And that's the second book in the works.
So, we basically told you everything
that we've been doing and where we're
going and what we want to do. And if you
feel led in any kind of way to support
this ministry, you can by going to
candidtruth.org.
We got a lot of different ways to give.
>> You saw that we had the PayPal. We also
have a lot of cool t-shirts. Check out
our shop on canofruth.org.
And um if you want to reach out to us
personally, if you still, you know, want
to know more details about what we're
doing before you give your money or
something, we are a tax deductible uh
organization. So, you can get that tax
deductible um what do you call that? A
gift receipt or whatever.
>> Your tax a receipt. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> For that.
>> And like I said, we can't do this
without you. I want to give this away.
I'm trying to figure out how to give it
away. Uh, I feel like we need
a trivia or something.
>> That's the second time I think I've seen
hats yet.
>> All right, here's a trivia. What is
behind Oh, hats. Yeah, we need we need
hats. What is behind me? It's been
behind me the whole time on this table.
the f the first one to tell me what's on
this little table behind me in the chat.
We will put you on screen and we'll ask
you to email us and you'll get to win
the I know him card game.
Does anybody know? You can put it in the
chat. There's some not not the tree.
There's something on this table.
>> A different
>> was it shown?
>> Mhm.
>> So that was a little clue, I guess. I'm
trying to think of something fun, a way
that you guys can
can get this card game
free. All right, Kim Kim,
>> you are the winner. Can of truth.
>> This is not me.
>> Mug.
Oh, you don't have trouble. Okay, Carol
with a K.
You guys both
got it right. But okay, so Kim Kim
forfeited.
Carol with a K, do you got people you
want to play this with or you want to
give it on to Sylvia?
>> Can't truth coffee. All right, Carol
with a K, we got you.
>> Give us, you already know our email, so
hit us up with your address and we will
send that your way.
>> Guys, thank you so much for always
supporting us. We love you. We thank
you. We cannot do this without you. And
if you've already been a supporter
financially, we see you. We thank you.
And we, you know, we love getting stuff
in the mail even from you guys. We get
books sometimes. We get letters and um
we just love all that stuff. It's so
encouraging and and supportive. You
don't know how much it means to us to
get that kind of support because we get
a lot of spiritual attacks, even haters
and all that kind of stuff. So, it's
just awesome to uh see you guys love and
support.
>> You got any final words?
>> Nope. Just thank you guys so much and we
we love you.
>> We love you. We'll see you next time,
guys.